bienvenue à tous et leur de parlement
hebdo le rendez-vous des chaînes
parlementaires 45 minutes pour refaire
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
avec michaël szames s blocage pénurie de
carburant perturbations manifs et grèves
la contestation contre la loi qui
réforme le travail ne faiblit pas le
gouvernement cherche désespérément
comment sortir de la crise et chacun
campe sur ses positions
manuel valls ne cède pas philippe
martinez non plus à l'origine de la
colère l'article 2 qui fait primer
l'accord d'entreprise sur l'accord de
branche
il sème la zizanie au plus haut sommet
de l'état on ne touchera pas à cet
article par le matignon et françois
hollande et au milieu du tumulte les
députés ont débattu sur la loi sapin 2
qui renforce la lutte contre la
corruption la transparence dans les
entreprises le vote des actionnaires sur
les rémunérations des dirigeants serait
contraignant c'est en tout cas ce que
prévoit un amendement socialiste voté en
séance
notre invité pour commenter toute cette
actualité très riche je me dois paris
bonjour bonjour vous êtes débuté les
républicains maire de châlons en
champagne très proche évidemment dans la
jupe et on parlera de toute cette
campagne autour d'alain juppé dans la
dernière partie avec notre partenaire du
figaro va commencer évidemment cette
semaine qu'il tient avec les blocages
ont toujours
et oui lundi la france qui redécouvre la
pénurie et les files d'attentes
raffineries bloquées stations services à
sec les opposants à la loi travail
maintiennent la pression pour que le
gouvernement retire son texte
pas question de céder pour matignon face
à face tendu avec philippe martinez
chacun joue sa crédibilité sandra
cerqueira et vous comprendrez que
évidemment je sois très déterminé le
gouvernement et le premier ministre en
particulier joue un jeu dangereux
un dialogue de sourds entre manuel valls
et philippe martinez
le face-à-face vire à l'affrontement
manuel valls inflexible ne peut se
permettre de céder du terrain
ces anciens ces conservateurs prendre
ainsi en otage les consommateurs notre
économie continue et des actions qui
visent à faire retirer le texte mais ça
n'est pas démocrate jiabao en chute
libre dans les sondages et fragilisé par
une partie de sa majorité
toute nouvelle concession sur la loi
travail est impensable
manuel valls est contraint d'être ferme
d'afficher son autorité tenir bon pour
montrer sa capacité à réformer plutôt
d'être dans une posture qui donne notre
point de vue est plus une posture de
préparation d'une future candidature aux
présidentielles qu'une écoute réelle des
attentes des salariés des citoyens de ce
pays il ya un gouvernement qui est
autoritaire qui refuse tout débat en
face philippe martinez qui continue de
demander le retrait de la loi n'a lui
aussi pas beaucoup plus de marge de
manoeuvre
arrivé à la tête d'un syndicat en pleine
crise il est contraint de radicaliser sa
ligne philippe martinez joue son va tout
il en va de la survie de la cgt
menacé par la montée en puissance de la
cfdt alors manuel valls watine tenir bon
face à philippe martinez comme par
exemple gerhard schröder en son temps
qui conduisait sans faillir la forme de
marché travaillant en allemagne s'il
peut permettre la comparaison une limite
quand même c'est que dans les réformes
de gerhard schröder il y avait des
contenus dans la réforme du code du
travail qu'on nous propose il n'y a plus
beaucoup de contenu y avait quelque
chose de raisonnable dans ce qu'on
appelait la v1 la version 1
qui a été très largement expurgé avant
même d'arriver au conseil des ministres
et donc au parlement et la v2 que nous
avons et les petites choses mais enfin
qui reste des petites choses donc là ni
comparaison avec rares chanteurs qui lui
a vraiment réformer allemagne est ce
qu'on nous propose là atteint me semble
t'il à dire qu'il faut qu'ils tiennent
et qui mesure qui ne supprime pas ce
soir je pense qu'il ne faut pas
effectivement supprimer cette loi le mon
raisonnement serait le suivant chaque
fois me paraît pas exceptionnellement
bonne il n'y a pas grand chose dans peu
de contenu et j'ai envie de vous dire
tout ça pour ça une fois cette la cette
loi existe et qu'elle est contestée
comme les contester lâcher ses saper
l'autorité de la démocratie l'autorité
de l'état
parce que ça consisterait à dire que
celui qui bloque on casse et violent a
raison contre celui qui est le tenant de
la démocratie le représentant légitime
de démocratie et la démocratie ne doit
pas lâcher que le pouvoir soit de droite
ou de gauche ne doit pas lâcher face aux
casseurs face à la cgt c'est la cgt qui
gouvernent aujourd'hui en l'occurrence
et la cgt qui essaient de gouverner qui
essaient de gouverner dans la rue mais
qui sait de gouverner aussi si j'ai bien
compris dans les médias on a un peu trop
passer sous silence qui s'est passé hier
mais qui est quand même un truc
totalement surréaliste une tentative de
prise de contrôle éditorial des médias
sous peine de grève soit vous passer mes
messages
soit vous ne paraissait pas davantage de
médias c'est une chantage à la
démocratie c'est une chantage aux médias
qui est probablement scandaleuses les
prémices de choses qu'on a vues dans
d'autres temps et qu'on voudrait pas
voir en france un petit peu plus tard
dans la semaine manuel valls s'est
exprimé devant l'hémicycle vous propose
de l'écouter parce que c'est toujours
une relation avec la cgt
je respecte cette organisation
son histoire ses militants et ses
dirigeants
ma porte est toujours ouverte pour le
dialogue mais la cgt ne fait pas la loi
dans ce pays
est ce que la cgt outre pas son rôle
bien sûr la cgt outre pas son rôle
la cgt a le rôle de défendre ses
syndiqués donc manuel valls a le rôle à
l'ordre ses salariés a le rôle de
défendre effectivement son point de vue
en reste dans des bornes démocratiques
qui sont ce qu'elles sont et pas plus un
parti d'extrême droite
qu'un syndicat d'extrême gauche n'a le
droit de bloquer le pays
c'est pareil les comportements sont les
mêmes les attitudes sont les mêmes
le parti pris de ces extrémismes qui
consiste à dire j'ai raison et donc
écrasé vous parce que c'est ça le
message que veut passer la cgtg raison
je représentais salariés au nom de quoi
j'en sais rien distille qu'ils repensent
des syriens est donc écrasé vous parce
que j'ai raison mais comment fait ça
perdre et moi de vous dire effectivement
que je comprends parfaitement l'attitude
du premier ministre connu là qui
consiste à dire la loi c'est le
parlement la loi c'est pas la série
quelques petites faire de plus à part
dire ça clairement on tenir bon tenir
ferme scène a débloqué négocier sans
même ouvrir la loi honte et ouvrira la
porte tout le temps toujours bien
évidemment la cgt janeiro comprendre que
la cgt fait il ya un truc est très
simple dans une démocratie on discute le
plus longtemps possible
et puis ensuite il revient aux pouvoirs
politiques de trancher d'arbitré de
prendre la décision
et ce n'est en aucun cas au pouvoir
politique de lâchers contre un syndicat
dont ce n'est pas la fonction
si la cgt veut basculer dans le champ
politique qu'ils passent par le parti
communiste pour le faire qui nous
montrent qu'ils sont capables de faire
un peu plus que 4 ou 5% aux élections il
nous paraît vraiment une majorité mais
c'est pas ça c'est que chacun son métier
chacun dans son rôle chacun dans sa
fonction démocratique le le rôle d'un
syndicat et de représenter des salariés
de discuter avec le patronat de discuter
avec le gouvernement sont égales en
europe et une fois que la discussion est
close
si un constat de désaccord jusqu'à
preuve
au contraire c'est pas le syndicat qui
doit emporter on va y revenir mais je
vous propose de reprendre le cours des
affaires parlementaires puisque la
justice était à l'ordre du jour mardi
les députés ont voté deux textes l'un
pour rendre la justice plus efficace
avec des dispositions qui facilite par
exemple divorce et un projet de loi
organique pour réformer le statut des
magistrats
le texte examiné en première lecture
porté par jean jacques urvoas et la
dernière grande gloire du quinquennat
alors benoist apparu contrairement à la
loi travail ce texte sans plutôt
consensuel il prévoit notamment le
divorce par consentement mutuel sans
juge votre galère ont majoritairement
voté contre pour vous ce projet ne va
pas dans l'intérêt des français il ya
des choses qui sont pas inintéressants
dans se plonger là je pense que
notamment des charges et les tribunaux
d'un embouteillage liées aux procédures
de divorce par consentement mutuel
peut être une bonne chose par contre il
ya d'autres éléments dans ce texte de
loi qui ne correspondaient pas au choix
et elle est qu'un député républicain
c'est donc on n'a pas le souhaitait le
voter je pense par exemple que tous les
débats autour du csm ne me paraissent
pas en reste c'est super et ratures ne
me semble pas correspondre à ce que l'on
m'attend moi je souhaite qu'on ait un
évidement une indépendance du csm et la
composition ne nous convient pas tous
les débats autour notamment de la
liberté entre guillemets des juges me
paraît indispensable du procureur me
paraît tout aussi indispensable par
contre il ya une différence me
semble-t-il essentiel c'est que procure
à représente l'autorité de l'état
mais je ne souhaite pas de ce point de
vue là qu'on coupe le lien organique
entre procureurs elle étale sur les
procédures pénales le texte va aussi la
suppression des tribunaux pour mineurs
dont on dit qu'ils ne se servent pas à
grand chose
c'est une mesure emblématique de nicolas
sarkozy vous trouvez que c'est une
décision logique
je ne trouve pas que ce soit une
décision logique quand une juridiction
une administration quelle qu'elle soit
ne fonctionne pas on se pose la question
de savoir pourquoi elle fonctionne pas
est-ce qu'on peut la réforme et parce
qu'elle me paraissait avoir un sens
la justice des mineurs est une justice
atypique avec des réglementations et des
lois atypique il faut donc me semble
t'il des juridictions atypique avait
fait sous le quinquennat précédent en
matière de justice a été
ayez globalement oui et notamment des
mesures qui me paraissait essentiel
comme les peines plancher
je vous rappelle l'idée des peines
planchers c'était de dire que certes il
ya des peines plafond ou take on vous
dit vous êtes condamné susceptibles de
dix ans de prison
c'est ce qu'on appelle un plafond mais
l'idée c'était de dire peut-être qu'il
faut mettre un plancher pour
qu'effectivement notamment les
multirécidivistes ne prenne n'écope pas
de petites peines de prison et que le
juge soit quelque part contraint de dire
au minimum 7 ans donc si vous revenez au
pouvoir c'est quelque chose les peines
brûle chez nous nous avons effectivement
proposé dans le programme qui a présenté
alain juppé sur la justice le retour sur
des peines planchers pour
qu'effectivement il y ait un plafond
c'est normal un plancher ça me paraît
normal aussi benoist apparu dans
l'actualité parlementaire encore on a
entendu ce coup de gueule des chercheurs
notamment des prix nobel français qui se
sont mobilisés contre les coupes
budgétaires vous propose les
explications de jean baptiste de glace
on y revient juste à temps pour la
commission des finances ces nombres pas
question de couper 114 millions d'euros
dans les crédits de la recherche et de
l'enseignement supérieur comme le
souhaiterait pourtant le gouvernement
pour faire des économies
il ya eu un vote en commission à une
très large majorité pour dire qu'on ne
pouvait pas rêver ainsi le budget de ces
organismes comme le cnrs qui prépare
l'avenir
le vote de la commission des finances
est simplement consultatif le
gouvernement n'est pas obligé de le
respecter mais symboliquement c'est un
désaveu les députés de gauche comme de
droite ils sont opposés
ça n'est pas dans le domaine de la
recherche qu'il faut pratiquer les
coupes de manière prioritaire c'est
toutes les voies de droite et de gauche
qui se sont unis pour dire attention à
la recherche trouvons d'autres solutions
et beaucoup de solutions d'ailleurs ont
été proposées en commission des finances
on est à la disposition du gouvernement
pour lui trouver des solutions quelques
minutes plus tard pendant les questions
au gouvernement la ministre de
l'éducation nationale a promis que les
coupes ne changerait rien au quotidien
des chercheurs les annulations qui sont
prévus dans le cadre de ce décret
d'avant ce sont des mesures qui n'auront
aucun impact sur l'activité des
organismes de recherche
il s'agit de
re calibrer les fonds de roulement et
les trésoreries de ces organismes
sans que jamais les dépenses de ces
organismes l'exécution de leur budget
les conditions de travail des chercheurs
ne soit affectée najat vallaud belkacem
espère rassurer un monde de la recherche
en ébullition depuis deux jours des
chercheurs de premier plan ont tiré le
signal d'alarmé sur les coupes
budgétaires par le gouvernement ont fait
des choix budgétaires vous dans le
programme d'alain juppé vous proposer
entre 85 et 100 milliards d'économies
il va donc falloir aussi faire des choix
est ce que la recherche est ce que
l'écologie pourrait être aussi victime
de ses choix budgétaires la recherche
n'ont jamais savez en france on a
beaucoup de débats sur ce qu'on appelle
la compétitivité et on se compare avec
les autres en termes de compétitivité la
recherche en fête commence entre souvent
nos questions de compétitivité sur ce
qu'on appelle la compétitivité coût de
dire le coût du travail mais il ya ce
qu'on appelle aussi la compétitivité
hors coûts et dans la compétitivité orco
vous avez les éléments de code du
travail
dale oen camry d'antan pas au parlement
et puis vous avez surtout ces éléments
d'innovation qui sont la conséquence
d'une recherche
autrement dit pour préparer la
croissance dans cinq ans dans dix ans
dans le quinze ans si nous devons faire
un choix
c'est d'investir dans la recherche dans
l'innovation c'est ça qui préparent
l'avenir donc pour moi il faut non
seulement pas y toucher mais il faut
augmenter les crédits liés au transfert
de technologies liées à l'innovation
pour que notre pays soit plus compétitif
en la matière pour eux parce que c'est
ça qui va préparer l'avenir et en
crédits pour la position en justice que
pour la recherche je pense que notamment
sur les questions de vrai quand vous
n'avez plus beaucoup dessous de vous
faire des économies vous devez prioriser
encore plus votre choix et prioriser
c'est quoi ces dires sait jamais c'est
jamais simple c'est dire par exemple
effectivement qu'il faut sur la justice
sur la sécurité être à zéro ou c'est pas
être à plus c'est être à zéro et jouer
sur les équilibres par rapport à ça mais
sur la recherche pour ce qui me concerne
je serais volontiers partant pour faire
des investissements massifs en matière
de recherche
enfin dernier point si vous voulez bien
par rapport à l'argumentaire de la
ministre les deux à la finale qui est
assez intéressant alors justement ce
qu'elle a dit la vérité
je ne sais pas on touche pas je ne sais
pas
pas obligé de chercheurs elle a dit
qu'elle le trouve intéressant c'est quoi
il ya vraiment un point de
fonctionnement qui me pose problème si
je comprends bien on parle de plus d'une
centaine de millions d'euros
c'est pas dans 14 exactement 114 pas
très précis c'est pas des petits sous
c'est pas des petits budgets et donc si
je comprends bien nous pourrions dans lé
budget du cea commissariat à l'énergie
atomique et du cnrs
les deux grandes institutions de
recherche tous et nous pourrions trouver
114 millions d'euros
comme ça sans aucun problème sans que
cela ne pose aucun problème sur le
fonctionnement du sénat sans que ça ne
pose aucun problème sur l'investissement
de la recherche
enfin si c'est vrai c'est grave pourquoi
c'est grave parce que ça veut dire qu'on
pourrait trouver 115 millions d'euros
en même temps ou comme ça d'un coup sans
aucun problème non non vous promets sait
rien du tout c'est juste un peu de
trésorerie qui voudra croyez pas ça veut
dire qu'on pourrait gratter donc de deux
choses l'une soit c'est faux ou et c'est
grave soit c'est vrai et c'est tout
aussi grave parce que les ses 115
millions d'euros quelque part dormir
dans des institutions de recherche parce
que s'ils ne servent à rien s'ils ne
sont pas graves
ça veut dire qu'il dormait et là c'est
tout aussi grand qu'il en soit c'est
grave alors on revient mercredi la crise
sociale par élise la france et le
gouvernement tente de trouver une issue
de secours
policiers et gendarmes sont intervenus
pour débloquer des raffineries au nom du
rétablissement de l'ordre public la
manière forte oui mais jusqu'au faut-il
réquisitionner les grévistes certains le
souhaitent mais le gouvernement compte
ses forces et ses moyens olivier boulenc
le gouvernement le dis clairement il ne
laissera pas le mouvement de grève dans
les raffineries paralyser le pays
on doit aussi faire en sorte qu'en même
temps qu'on libère des dépôts qu'on
assure l'approvisionnement
on le fasse avec le souci à la fois de
l'ain de la mesure mais la détermination
est réaffirmé et total pour cela l'état
dispose de plusieurs moyens lever les
blocages comme à douchy les mines ou fos
sur mer par exemple faciliter le
transport des hydrocarbures en arrêté
publié par alain vidalies ce mercredi
matin permet aux livreurs de déroger aux
règles en matière
de temps de conduite et de repos puiser
dans les réserves
c'est ce que fait l'état depuis quelques
jours il est possible de tenir comme ça
quatre mois autre mesure que la droite
appelle de ses voeux
réquisitionner le personnel gréviste une
mesure pour l'instant écartée par
l'exécutif
même si elle n'est pas tabou lorsque des
salariés vont empêcher d'autres salariés
de travailler c'est-à-dire font des
blocages à ce moment là le gouvernement
intervient et la réquisition n'est pas
un mot tabou une mesure déjà utilisé en
2010 lors de la contestation sur la
réforme des retraites une limitation du
droit de grève
autorisé par la loi quand elle concerne
les secteurs dits stratégiques
c'est le cas des hôpitaux par exemple
seulement voilà le secteur pétrolier
n'en fait a priori pas partie il y a 6
ans un tribunal administratif avait
cassé un arrêté de réquisition du préfet
de seine et marne
celui ci avait dû invoquer un possible
trouble à l'ordre public pour obliger
une partie du personnel à travailler
alors la situation ne s'arrange pas loin
de là est ce qu'il faut dans ce cas
réquisitionné les personnels grévistes
comme la droite l'avait fait en 2010 est
ce que ce serait marquée l'autorité de
l'état
oui bien sûr partir devant nous nous
considérons que ces blocages touche des
secteurs stratégiques pour l'économie
française
c'est le cas c'est le cas bien
évidemment à partir du moment où nous
considérons qu effectivement il y à un
risque pour l'économie française
pour que on le voit bien on a faim de
partisans déjà qu'ils ne peuvent plus
travailler parce qu'ils n'ont plus
d'essence chez moi à châlons en
champagne
on n'a pas été touché par les problèmes
de pénurie mais on voit bien on
rencontre les artisans leur inquiétude
parce que si vous prenez un maçon
électricien sa cabine est lui est
indispensable pour travailler
et s'il n'a plus d'essence il ne peut
plus travailler quand on en arrive à des
situations ce type là oui me semble-t-il
il faut additionner et l'avis de la
france sont menacées évidemment que les
intérêts économiques de la france sont
menacées à partir du moment où vous avez
les français qui ne travaillent plus ou
qui ne peuvent pas travailler à partir
du moment où vous avez effectivement un
symbole de secteur d'activité et que
deux mais qui n'ont plus la capacité de
travail et il faut en tirer toutes les
conséquences selon vous de près ministre
ne prend pas cet engagement de réduire
poserai la question j'imagine qu'il
connaît
exposé dans les médias il n'a pas
répondu la médecine que c'est pour lui
un pas de plus dans la fermeté qui ne
veut pas franchir
j'ajoute et c'est peut-être là si on va
être juste sur le raisonnement on a bien
entendu dans votre reportage qui fait
des problèmes juridiques
mais dès qu'on peut réquisitionner dans
un centre de secteur six secteurs en
question aujourd'hui ne sont pas
réquisitionna bhl il faut probablement
revoir la liste en question pour se dire
qu'effectivement le secteur des
hydrocarbures
le secteur énergétique et loyal
mécaniquement faire partir cette liste
parce que si effectivement ce secteur
n'alliez pas je vois pas ce qui pourrait
y être dans les transports le service
minimum mais ce qu'il faudrait le mettre
en place également pour tout le service
de l'énergie
je parle du pétrole je parle des
centrales nucléaires je pense que tout
ce qui fait que ton centrales nucléaires
c'est une évidence la question sinon je
n'arrive déjà pas à imaginer un seul
instant que les grévistes aux arrêtés
une centrale nucléaire
tellement sa professeure j'arrive pas à
y croire il y avait même des jeunes
osent enfin j'imagine un instant ce que
doit être en ce moment l'image
internationale de la france
elle est pas bonne j'interviendrai
exceptionnels notamment pour ce qui
concerne la capacité qu'on a travaillé
en france la compétitivité du pays sur
son attractivité la tient responsable de
la dégradation de cette image
les deux le gouvernement d'un côté les
syndicats notre donc le gleut un
gouvernement
oui je pense que le gouvernement est
évidemment responsable pourquoi parce
que le gouvernement je vous rappelle
l'histoire de ce texte doit quand ce
qu'on appelle avait un sort la version 1
sort elle n'a pas été négocié avec
quiconque
y'a pas un syndicat sur la verne qui a
été négocié avec le gouvernement pour
préparer ce texte de loi
on a des premiers mouvements notamment
du côté étudiants on stoppe ce texte
avant qu'il arrive au conseil des
ministres
pendant quinze jours vont négocier un
épisode je suis pour négocier autrement
dit on négocie après que le taxi
technique c'était il ya une faute du
gouvernement effectivement en matière de
négociation syndical sur ce texte de loi
une précipitation une volonté de se
montrer comme encore un réformateur dans
l'âme
re année parce qu'on est sur des choix
principalement tactique permettant à
françois hollande de se représenter ou
non et donc l'erreur majeure du
gouvernement est évidemment une erreur
de méthode et aujourd'hui on en arrive à
cet enchaînement qui fait un truc
absolument fabuleux fabuleux en termes
d' analyse politique c'est qu'on a un
texte dont les contenus sont
relativement faibles et qui provoque un
encart total pendant pays
c'est cette contradiction là à la limite
je me dirais on aurait des contenus
puissant dans le texte de loi
on y verrait se dire ok et légitimité
forme de légitimité à ces contestations
smm pacaya rien on part justement me
reste l'article 2 peut-être à négocier
ou à tout ça avec céline martel crif qui
rêvent comme solution pour sortir de la
crise un article créé la pagaille dans
la majorité
l'article 2 du projet de loi travail
censé donner la primauté aux accords
d'entreprises sur les accords de branche
bruno le roux chef des députés
socialistes à l'assemblée évoque de
possibles concessions à ce principe
avant de se faire moins affirmatif je
pense qu'il y à une discussion qui doit
être ouverte sur le fait de laisser le
paiement des heures supplémentaires à
l'appréciation d'un accord d'entreprise
ou de faire en sorte que ce soit ce qui
a été discuté dans l'accord de branche
je pense que cette question doit être
ouverte
je n'ai jamais parlé de réécriture
réécriture ça voudrait dire changer la
logique face à des députés socialistes
très divisés sur cette réforme il semble
que le premier ministre tâtonne entre
discours de fermeté et volonté de ne pas
braquer sa majorité
mesdames et messieurs les députés ni
retrait du texte ni remise en cause de
l'article 2 cas c'est le coeur de la
philosophie du texte
il peut toujours y avoir des
modifications des améliorations seul
michel sapin et explicite on peut
maintenir et le texte et les discussions
principale et a dominé le dialogue
peut-être qu'il faut toucher à l'article
de recadrage immédiat du premier
ministre par matinale interposée ne
touchera pas à l'article 2 on peut
toujours mais on peut toujours améliorer
tout chez tel ou tel aspect on peut
toujours le droit pas toucher à
l'article 2
il dit tout à l'heure mais la
philosophie de l'article de la
négociation dans l'entreprise ça on n'y
touchera pas depuis le japon le
président de la république poursuit la
bataille sémantique et déclare ce qu'a
dit valls sur l'article 2 est ce qu'il
fallait dire et françois hollande est
allé plus loin cette fin de semaine
parce qu'il avait qu'il irait jusqu'au
bout lui aussi comment on sort de la
crise déjà on a la une un montage qui
est sublime
on touche on touche pas on touche on
touche pas une petite virgule part si
effectivement on a souvent parlé de
couacs depuis le début de ce quinquennat
là on avait quand même une image assez
extraordinaire cette le sentiment que
nous pouvons avoir capag ligne et qu' il
n'y a pas au sein du gouvernement avec
sa majorité son groupe parlementaire
une cohérence intellectuelle une
cohérence idéologique une cohérence dans
les mesure où effectivement grosso modo
ils ont fixé les bornes à ne pas
dépasser
et là on voit bien en écoutant trois
personnalités importantes le miz des
finances le président du groupe
le premier ministre qu'on a trois
positions différentes et qu'on sait
toujours pas si on touchera donc moins
ce que j'attends déjà du gouvernement de
la majorité c'est qu'il y ait un front
uni si on veut tenir il faut un front
uni avec la vocation à 100 à 120 le
sentiment on dit souvent que celui qui
le plus fort c'est celui qui est le plus
uni quel plus cohérent là les français
quand ils écoutent ça qu'est-ce qui les
entendent x positions divergentes au
sein de la majorité et donc pour tenir
il faut dans un premier temps qui ligne
de cohérence une colonne vertébrale
cohérente entre les uns et les autres
une question benoist apparu si la motion
de censure arrive au mois de juillet
motion de censure déposée par la gauche
est ce que vous écoutez le droit vous
voteriez cette motion c'est une blague
c'est pas la question a été posée la
formule consacrée maintenant entre les
journalistes et les les politiques c'est
une plaisanterie
évidemment que non je ne voterai pas
cette motion de censure je rappelle
qu'il me censure sur la base d'une
mesure ce texte nous ne sommes pas
d'accord avec le gouvernement pour telle
était la raison vous imaginez donc que
la droite va signer avec lestrem
une espèce de plateforme politique
commune pour dire voilà pourquoi nous
voulons rendre voter cette mission il
fera ce qu'il veut d'accord mais pour ce
qui me concerne je considère que c'est
une blague premier point deuxième
élément
je vous rappelle que le la conséquence
logique pas obligatoire mais logique
d'une motion de censure votée adopté
c'est que le gouvernement tombe ça c'est
une obligation et qu'ensuite il doit y
avoir normalement une dissolution
ça veut dire si je comprends bien qu'à
la crise économique sociale
on voit sur de rajouter une bonne crise
dont vous les politiques la crise pour
être sûrs et évidemment qu'en 2017
marine le pen remporté là c'est un peu
de sérieux un peu sérieux ne ferait de
mal à personne
alors revenons à du sérieux et aux
questions de sécurité qui sont à la une
mercredi toujours puisque bernard
cazenave à dévoyer les mois il a dévoilé
les moyens déployés par don effective et
dispositifs pour l'euro 2016 qui
commence très bientôt écouter
j'entends les objections formulées par
ceux qui considèrent que ses fans zone
aurait dû être abandonné mais je pose à
ce moment là la question comment s
contre est il que la sécurité de
supporters disent porte dispersés en
tout point des villes dans des lieux
ouverts et dont l'accès ne serait pas
par définition contrôler puisse être
assurée et bien entendu nous nous
réservons la possibilité à tout moment
en fonction des informations dont nous
pourrions disposer d' adapter jusqu'à la
dernière minute
notre dispositif de manière à ce que la
fête soit au rendez vous par un haut
niveau de sécurité garantie pas sur les
fans zone qui cristallise le débat est
là dit on les maintient
sauf événements exceptionnels vous
pensez que le gouvernement prend un
risque majeur en refusant d'annuler ses
fans sont au contraire ils en sont les
raisons la raison de tenir bon coup sûr
c'est sur ses fans zone pour quoi il est
question de sécurité on va avoir des
milliers les millions de spectateurs
français comme étrangers qui vont venir
dans les villes qui organisent des
matchs pour participer à la fête au
niveau du match et pour ceux qui
n'auront pas de billet pour rentrer dans
les stades
pour pouvoir regarder les matchs en
question miser l'intérieur l'audit façon
très juste
qu'est ce que vous préférez un endroit
sécurisé fermé où on peut contrôler les
accès ou d'avoir 50 groupes 300 groupes
qui au hasard d'une ville se balade se
rassemblent dans un endroit non prévus
pour ça pour regarder le match
sincèrement en termes de sécurité je
crois que la fan zone est beaucoup plus
efficace premier point deuxième point ne
reculons pas devant la peur devant le
risque s'est donné raison aux
terroristes que de lâcher si l'on
considère un moment ou un autre qu'on ne
peut plus faire la fête en france que la
france ne peut plus organiser des
manifestations internationales
rappelez vous on a eu le même débat sur
la cap 21 certains préconisent et dont
ils ont 10 ans ou là la coupe 21 c'est
dangereux ne faisons pas non au
contraire il faut faire pour ne pas
donner et faire comprendre aux la morale
politique aux terroristes et faire
confiance bien évidemment aux forces de
l'ordre
et donc je crois en effet que le
gouvernement a raison de maintenir ces
fans d'ozone
c'est plus facile à sécuriser une
démultiplication spectateurs partout
dans une vie un contrôle arrêt deuxième
élément c'est effectivement tenir bon
face à ceux qui veulent miner notre
démocratie
je laisse un peu les questions de
sécurité d'un côté pour passer un peu
aux prestations sociales c'est une
proposition de loi d'un sénateur et
l'air de votre parti qui a été examinée
cette semaine en commission
il vise à renforcer les contrôles contre
les fraudeurs sandra sarano explique
tout seul
la fraude aux aides sociales notamment
le rsa c'est plus de 140 millions
d'euros chaque année pour lutter contre
cette fraude
eric doligé sénateur les républicains
proposent de donner plus de pouvoir aux
départements afin de sanctionner voire
supprimer les aides en cas d'abus
aujourd'hui les personnels de la caf
peuvent avoir des informations sur leurs
ressortissants et ceux ci peuvent être
des bénéficiaires du rsa puisque c'est
la caf qui distribue les sommes que le
conseil général lui verse et le conseil
général n'a pas le moyen de contrôler et
on lui refuse d information donc
l'objectif c'est qu'on ne puisse plus
les refuser de l'information et qu'il y
ait du personnel à gré au conseil
général à gauche on estime que ce n'est
pas la lutte contre la fraude sociale
qui aidera à améliorer l'état des
finances locales
ça sera très très très très modeste
comme comme résultat et ça participe de
ce courant de pensée générale qui est
que beaucoup de gens sont celles de de
fraudes et de vivre sur le dos de l'état
et du contribuable est bon c'est pas ça
les vrais problèmes de la france
aujourd'hui
la proposition de loi sera débattue en
séance le 31 mai prochain mais certains
départements n'ont pas attendu une loi
pour agir dans l'eure et le haut rhin
par exemple les bénéficiaires du rsa se
voit désormais réclamer des relevés
bancaires pour justifier leur droit à
percevoir cette allocation
deux exemples que vous citez sandra
cerqueira savez exemple efficace selon
vous il faut faire cela en tout cas cet
essai dans un département
regardons si ça une efficacité ou pas a
priori moi j'étais plutôt sceptique sur
l'idée de demander leurs revenus
bancaires
les relevés bancaires pardon mais
testons le dans le département en
question on verra bien si ça marche ou
ça marche pas un mot peut-être sur ce
qu'a dit sénateur socialiste je trouve
assez intéressant
certes je partage un point avec lui
c'est probablement une minorité qui
fraudent mais justement parce que les
français ont le sentiment que tout le
monde fraude que tout est un dû il faut
être encore plus dur sur la fraude pour
que les français retrouvent le goût
l'esprit de la solidarité
le rsa n'est pas un problème en soi le
rsa c'est l'engagement solidaire d'un
pays vis-à-vis de ceux qui n'ont pas lu
tout revenu c'était une bonne chose ce
n'est pas de l'assistanat c'est pas
l'assistanat mais le revenu de
solidarité active est dans son principe
mines est remis en cause par beaucoup de
nos compatriotes parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment que tout le monde fraude que
c'est un dû pour tout le monde et donc
si nous devons si nous voulons pardon
garantir ces principes de solidarité qui
sont nécessaires à notre pays pour les
plus fragiles
il faut être très dur très ferme contre
les fraudeurs et même si ça repart pas
beaucoup dessous au département c'est
pas grave on ignorait les français
auront la certitude que le rsa est juste
donc le département c'est le bon échelon
pour lutter contre ces fraudes qui dit
sont le fait de nos gars
département qu'à la compétence sur le
terrain donc c'est évidemment à ces
défis pour cela que la fraude à
s'organiser vous rappeler que la lutte
contre la fraude contre on va
s'organiser ont appelé jeudi leurs
wauquiez à propos de l'assistanat aux
angles général n'est pas le cancer de la
société parce qu'ils avaient raison
j'aime pas ce mot j'aime assez terre
mais j'aime pas cette accusation entre
guillemets que l'on a contre tous ceux
qui touchent des revenus solidarité
quelqu'un parce qu on a deux
philosophies la v21 fille dans votre
propre d'une personne conclut fragilité
intellectuelle ce qu'on appelle les
handicapés mentaux
est-ce que vous avez sentiment qu'ils
sucent le sang du système est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment qu'ils sont dans
cet assistanat cancer de la société non
c'est normal que vis-à-vis de ce type de
public des fragiles l'état intervienne
département internet pour les aider
celui qui n'a pas de boulot depuis cinq
ans dix ans c'est normal de
l'accompagner pour le retour à l'emploi
et donc quelle est l'idée l'idée c'est
de se dire que nos valeurs de droite
sont des valeurs où on souhaite que les
gens travaillent parce qu'on considère
que le travail c'est l'émancipation
humaine et donc il faut positiver en
disant eh oui faut brosser en wauquiez
on peut avoir des différences en la
matière qui fera la différence
effectivement de ce point de vue là avec
laurent wauquiez au moi je considère que
le travail c'est l'émancipation de
l'homme et je ne souhaite pas avoir une
démarche accusatoire contre les uns et
les années de ligne politique oui au
travail aux hennuyers la sonorité est
très dure contre les fraudes pour
qu'effectivement on n'est pas d'un
amalgame rsa fraudeurs alors on va
parler d'une autre question un peu tabou
un peu certains maires celle des
rémunérations des grands patrons qui
revient dans le débat jeudi
mieux encadrer les salaires des
dirigeants d'entreprises publiques cette
mesure phare était à l'ordre du jour de
la loi 122 qui vise à lutter contre la
corruption la loi sapin 2 prévoit de
protéger et d'accompagner les lanceurs
d'alert ceux qui dénoncent les affaires
de corruption sébastien de naja
rapporteur du texte propose que cette
mission soit confié au défenseur des
droits
nos travaux nos auditions nous
conduisent à vous proposer dans cette
proposition de loi organique de faire du
défenseur des droits
autorités constitutionnellement protégés
dont l'indépendance est garantie par
notre constitution et par un texte
organique donc de faire du défenseur des
droits la clé de voûte de ce système de
traitement et de protection sur l'autre
disposition sensible la rémunération des
dirigeants michel sapin a rappelé la
volonté du gouvernement de légiférer
mais sans imposer de plafond une
limitation par la loi du montant de la
rémunération serait contraire à la
liberté des contrats et la liberté du
commerce et d'industrie sébastien de
naja a exposé sa solution rendre
contraignante les décisions des ag des
actionnaires disposition votée dans
l'hémicycle
l'idée de cet amendement est clair
éviter ce qui s'est produit chez renault
où le conseil d'administration a
confirmé la rémunération de carlos ghosn
malgré l'avis contraire des actionnaires
alors est ce que cette mesure votée en
première lecture serait pour vous un
progrès rendre contraignante mais
décision des actionnaires donc non
couverts enfin c'est quand même la
france est fascinant de ce point de vue
là on a un exemple d'une entreprise
d'une entreprise où le ca et l'ag en
branle des visions divergentes redon
l'amour ans et si je comprends bien
parce qu'on a un exemple 100% des boîtes
vont être concernés par cette loi
un problème réaliste ça on légifère pour
un cas on légifère pas pour avoir en
ayant réfléchi en ayant consulté en
ayant travaillé approfondie un sujet on
légifère au débotté du jour au lendemain
parce qu'à un cas qui a défrayé la
chronique il faut en france qu'on arrête
de gouverner sous prétexte qu'on a eu 24
heures de pression médiatique sur un
sujet où à chaque fois qu'on met une
pression médiatique
hop la réponse qu'il nous faut un
amendement une petite oie qui plus est
inséré ce genre
deux procédures de loi dans un texte sur
la corruption
l'image et des complexes moi j'avais cru
comprendre c'est pavlovien dans les
milieux politiques français avec les
danseurs des cons à 48 heures de presse
comme une loi où ça devient différente
quand je reprends une expression ce
simple mot nine tariqa données manuel
macro morizet co en début de semaine il
a probablement raison il faut arrêter de
légiférer en permanence sur tout et sur
rien parce qu'il ya eu 48 heures de
pression médiatique ou à passer
maintenant aux partenaires du scan qui
nous a rejoint aujourd'hui mme byrs a
fait aujourd hui calme notamment après
le jingle gym 7 à vos bons jours benoist
apparu au genre vous portez un certain
nombre de positions iconoclastes au sein
de votre parti républicain on se
souvient que vous étiez prononcé pour le
mariage pour tous en 2012 plus récemment
vous êtes opposé à l'annulation du
concert de black m
à verdun se souvient aussi et vous
l'avez dit vous ne réclamez pas
l'annulation la fermeture des fans zone
pour l'euro est ce que finalement c'est
siv juppéiste c'est prendre le
contre-pied de la direction du parti des
sarkozystes sur sur plusieurs sujets et
du pays s'il ya ce qu'on pense c'est
dans la majorité et c'est dans la
minorité du parti peu importe on dit ce
qu'on pense et on arrête peut-être de
calculer en permanence les choses à mon
électorat pense que donc la majorité du
parti pensent que donc je suis non le
rôle d'un politique crée plutôt
d'essayer de guider les choses et de
dire ce qu'il pense qu'il a au plus
profond de lui-même et de dire
simplement sa vérité ça plaît tant mieux
s'appeler pas j'allais vous dire quelque
part est pas suffisamment de liberté de
parole au sein du parti selon ces peines
qui sont libérés du père et par aga
souvent c'est pas le parti qui est en
cause en l'occurrence on a une totale
liberté par de parole sous la direction
de nicolas sarkozy ça pose aucun
problème en la matière c'est souvent les
calculs que nous faisons les uns et les
autres en se disant je reste dans la
ligne où je me cale par rapport à cette
ligne ans pour rencontre d'ailleurs elle
a certains qui sont fait une spécialité
du contre par principe nous c'est pas la
question qu'on se pose question qu'on se
pose c'est c'est juste c'est pas juste
on veut on veut pas en arbitrant
fonctionne ça
alors peut-être autre divergence que
black m je me rappelle que la position
d'alain juppé n'était pas tout à fait la
même autre divergence que vous avez
peut-être avec certains de vos camarades
vous vous l'avez dit vous ne réclamez
pas le retrait de la loi travail en 95
alain juppé avait fini par retirer le la
céder face à la rue sur la question des
retraites
est-ce qu'il avait eu tort oui je pense
que nous avions eu tort même si ça
devenait intenable en 95 et j'étais pas
suffisamment au fait des choses il
fallait tenir effectivement je pense
qu'il faut de tenir savez quelque part
mon raisonnement
ça vous paraître bizarre mais black m
l'ol comme risquées qui finalement
quelque part un peu le même pas bon je
pense qu'il ne fallait pas inviter black
m
pour les commémorations de 14 18 mais
une fois qu on l'invite on tient bon et
on n'annule pas l'autorité deux enjeux
les mails qui remettent en cause sa
plaie droit de faire ça s'appelle
quelque part oui nur adan c'est moi qui
s'appelle droit dans son autorité de
l'état
là encore la loi elle comme rit on l'a
évoqué telle heure c'est un texte qui me
paraît pas suffisamment allé assez loin
donc je ne le voterai pas est ce que
pour autant il faut le remettre en cause
sous prétexte que 50 casseurs 300
casseurs veulent le retrait de ce texte
de loi
réponse non parce que sinon c'est donner
raison aux casseurs et ça ça ne me
paraît totalement son trait à la loire à
nos pratiques tu donc alain juppé
n'aurait pas dû céder la rue à 495 il ne
cèdera pas à la rue si jamais il est élu
en 2017 et qu'une contestation sociale
massive se développe contre par exemple
ces ordonnances pour le club dans le
travail
heureusement soit 95 95 on a le même
problème
si on veut être sincère que le problème
de françois hollande
la campagne électorale de jacques chirac
est une campagne centrée sur ce qu'on
appelle à la fracture frétillant sociale
on n'a pas vraiment annoncé pendant
cette campagne électorale qu'on allait
réformer les retraites
réformer les régimes spéciaux réformés
l'assurance maladie et serrer la vis
budgétaire c'est pas du tout l'angle
d'un campagne électorale quand vous
faites une campagne là et que vous
gouvernez là ça ne marche pas et si vous
perdez votre légitimité à agir
vous devez cd
demande et donc tout l'enjeu pour 2010
et c'est quoi annoncer la couleur c'est
d'être précis d'annoncer la couleur
avant de façon détaillée et chiffrée
quantifier quitte à dire des choses qui
font mal quitte à dire des choses qui ne
plaisent pas si derrière on veut avoir
la légitimité de le faire vous pensez
que ça suffirait à empêcher une
manifestation jeudi la colère sociale
je sais pas si ça suffit à empêcher la
manifestion colère sociale mais deux
remarques si vous le voulez bien
la première c'est que le sous-entendu de
ce type de réflexion c'est quoi donc on
ne fait rien il ya un risque de manif
il ya un risque de blocage il ya un
risque de grève donc on ne fait rien
c'est pas ma conception de la vie
politique sinon je vais faire un autre
métier mais je vais pas commencer à me
dire tiens je réforme ça parce que c'est
pas trop dangereux ça c'est dangereux
j'ai touche pas parce qu'il ya un risque
de grave sinon on fait plus rien premier
élément est le deuxième élément moi j'ai
la perception le sentiment que si
effectivement on a la légitimité
populaire pour agir la légitimité des
urnes
on pourra agir y compris face au blocage
alain juppé va recevoir 1 nathalie
kosciusko morizet aujourd'hui à bordeaux
ils vont se voir cet après midi est
dit-on dîner même se voir ensemble
est-ce qu'il faut y voir les prémices
d'un rapprochement
il faut y voir que cette primaire c'est
une compétition pas un combat et si
demain nicolas sarkozy françois fillon
bruno le maire qui vous voulez rien à
bordeaux ou ailleurs
bien évidemment que les uns et les
autres se rencontrera franchement nous
sommes dans le même parti
nous avons vocation au lendemain
novembre à travailler ensemble pour
préparer la présidentielle et à
gouverner ensemble
on n'est pas elle doit pouvoir aller
jusqu'au bout de sa candidature de
pouvoir se présenter c'est important
selon vous c'est important d'avoir une
crème dans le dispositif de la primaire
bien sûr que c'est important mais
conférer au moins trois candidates à
partir du moment où comme tout le monde
est là les parrainages si elle n'a pas
les parrainages
malheureusement on ne pourra pas être il
n'y a pas de raison d'aidés qui qu on
n'est pas là pour se donner se refiler
mamaï est entre guillemets sont nés sur
des parrainages qu'ils ne vivent que
chacun effectivement arrive à récupérer
ses parrainages cette dernière question
dernière question emmanuel macron lens
ce week-end sa grande marche de son
opération de porte à porte en vue d'une
hypothétique candidature pourquoi pas
est ce que ce sera un tunnel gers
sérieux
et peut-être dangereux pour alain juppé
pourquoi partie parce qu'ils peuvent
partager ensemble de politiques communes
bus car si les candidats représentera
quand même plutôt la gauche mais a
priori nous ne représenterons quand même
plutôt la boîte et c'est dans le corps
mais le rite ou est ce que justement il
n'y a pas fait avant qu emmanuel macron
soit candidat à l'élection
présidentielle je pense que l'eau va
couler sous les ponts mais il faut
d'abord si je comprends bien que
françois l'on n'y aille pas donc il
faudrait qu'un président de la
république sortant n'a y pas la
présidentielle pas femme quand même
temps avec le premier ministre aille pas
pour que finalement le troisième larron
entre guillemets avec le soutien du ps
puisse y aller tous apparaît comme très
très très hypothétique merci beaucoup
merci djimé diallo apparu devant était
notre invité on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition de
parlement hebdo très bonne ces deux
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
ciao